[MUSIC PLAYING]
BELINDA LANGER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Belinda
Langner, and I
am a Product Manager
here at Google
working on our app ads products.
And today, we're going to talk
a lot about smart strategies
for growing your
business with ads.
It's really great to
be back here at I/O
and see all of the amazing
things that you're building.
I love this time of
year, because it really
energizes me to see how you
are all growing your businesses
and what kind of cool
apps you're developing.
Technology really offers
the opportunity for us
to live more fulfilling
and balanced lives.
And for me personally,
apps really
helped me unplug
after my daughter was
born exactly a year ago today.
But no worries, I'm
not going to make you
sing "Happy Birthday" to her.
She won't understand
anyways, right?
So one of the things that was
really important to me about
apps was, as becoming
a new parent,
I really wanted to
learn more about how
to be a really good parent.
As a first-time
mom, I really wanted
to make sure I wasn't
doing anything wrong.
And so as a natural person
who's really curious,
I wanted to read up on
all the possible books
to learn how to sleep
train my daughter,
to figure out how to get
her to eat properly--
you know, all the
basics in life, right?
And so the Libby app
helped me borrow ebooks
from my local library so
that all the cool books
that people were recommending
to me, I could read up on.
It helped me sync my bookmarks
across all of my devices.
So no matter where I was,
I was able to just take
a quick look at my apps
and see what was going on.
And it even let me beam
my books to my Kindle.
Also, if you've
ever had a baby, you
don't get a lot of
free time, but you
want to cool off
every so often, right?
And so I also wanted to unwind
by playing "Golf Masters."
And the nice thing
about this game
is that they're
such quick rounds,
so that I was able to get a
quick round in and just play
different courses really quickly
while my daughter was sleeping.
And so with billions
of users like me
across the world engaging
with mobile apps,
the opportunity for you is huge.
And competition is heating up.
Users have higher
expectations for your app,
so you really need to find a
way to stand out while growing
quickly and profitably.
And you want to find
the right users.
You want to find
those right customers
and convert them effectively.
And you need to create engaging,
user-friendly experiences.
So this means that both your
app and your advertising dollars
have to work really
hard to set you apart.
It's a lot to think about.
The good news is
that technology can
handle a lot of the heavy
lifting of your business
with ads.
And today, we're going to
talk a little bit about how
Google's smarter growth and
monetization strategies make
it easier for you to grow a
more profitable app business.
So I'm going to kick things
off by talking about some
of the few launches
that we're doing,
both for Google App Campaigns,
formerly known as UAC.
We'll talk a little bit about
some of the partnerships
that we're creating,
and then Duke
is going to talk about the
latest AdMob innovations that
make sure that you
help find smarter
monetization strategies.
So what are we waiting for?
Let's dive in, because this
is what you're all here for,
right?
Building a profitable
app business
is not just about installs
and daily actives.
I see a lot of head
shaking, so this really
resonates with you guys.
You all know that it takes
smart growth strategies focused
on converting high-value
users at the right time
and at the right price.
But today, it's not easy to
find advertisers and users that
will engage and transact.
With your limited
resources, how do you
acquire new, high-value users
to drive your business forward?
And how do you keep
their attention?
We're so busy these days.
It's so hard to make sure
that you even set aside time
to sit in this presentation,
to read up on the latest news,
to hang out with your family.
So how do you keep
people's attention
so that they not only
install, but use your app,
transact on your app, and
come back time and time again?
So we built Google
App Campaigns to help
you reach users who really
want to use your app in more
of the moments that they're
already hanging out in.
Our machine technology
helps handle the hard work
of helping you find the right
users across all of the Google
properties, including Google
Search, Google Play, YouTube,
and the 3 million sites
and apps in our network,
all in one campaign.
And we come to I/O every year
to listen to your feedback.
And we're working on unlocking
even more value for you
and the developer community.
So there are two
things that we need
to understand in order to
put our machine learning
to work for you.
First, we didn't
know which users
mattered the most to making
your business profitable.
When you think about
that perfect customer,
what are they doing?
Are they just installing
and using your app day in
and day out?
Are they getting through
the tutorials really fast?
Are they getting to certain
game levels really fast?
Are they making a purchase?
Knowing these critical moments
that these users are taking
helps drive value
for your business
and helps us find more users
who are similar to them.
And second, we want
to know, how do you
want to show up to new users
with your ad creatives?
What do you want them to
remember about your app?
Users are discovering apps in
more ways than ever before.
How do you want users to
interact with your ad?
Where do you want to find them?
Different users also want
different things from your app.
Having the right
inputs helps Google
deliver the most relevant ad
in every possible opportunity
that a user is looking for
because we're all different,
and we all want different
things from our apps.
So let's go ahead and jump to
answering that first question--
how to find new
users that matter.
Today in App Campaigns, we
offer two bidding strategies
to help you find
the right users.
And this really depends
on what your goal is.
We have TCPI, or Target
Cost Per Install,
which lets you bid
on users who install.
Tell us how much you want
to pay for each user who's
going to install, and
then we handle the rest.
Going one step
further, if you want
to focus on specific
actions, we have
a bidding option called TCPA,
or Target Cost Per Action.
This lets you bid on users who
not only install, but also take
a specific, valuable
action within your app.
Once you tell us which
conversions matter to you,
whether it be
subscribing, whether it
be making a purchase,
getting to a certain level,
spending a certain amount
of time in your app,
Google can now find people
who are likely to complete
these actions in the future.
So to recap, if you're simply
focused on finding installs,
then we have TCPI bidding
to help you find more users
at a certain cost per install.
If your business
model, though, depends
on acquiring users who will take
certain actions with your app,
then use TCPA bidding, or
Target Cost Per Action.
So I don't want
you just to hear it
from me, so I'm actually
going to show you a success
story from Maven--
an hourly car sharing and
rental service from GM.
Has anyone used them yet?
No?
Well, maybe you'll
try them later.
For Maven, the valuable in-app
actions they were looking
for are registrations--
the first steps that
users take to becoming
really active members.
And this is because
Maven recognized
that they need to acquire
not just any user, but users
that will help them
grow a very loyal base.
Let's take a look at their
experience bidding with TCPA
and how they used that to
optimize their ad campaigns.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Maven is an on-demand
car sharing service.
We launched in 2016.
We launched very quickly, with
eight markets in eight months.
- One of the biggest
challenges that we've had
was understanding
who are going to be
the right people to target,
to talk to, in order
to have them actually
become a member,
register, and then
use our service?
- These days, an install
or download isn't enough.
We're really looking to find
those high-value members.
- So we partnered with Google
to address our need of finding
high-value customers.
We've been able to increase
our registrations by 51%,
while decreasing our cost
per registration by 74%.
- One of the benefits of using
an automated campaign is that
you get to be more
of a strategist,
being able to look at it
from a 30,000-foot view
and understand, this is
the campaign as a whole.
It gives me a lot more line of
sight of what's in the future,
instead of what's just
immediately on the horizon.
- It does all the
hard work for us.
With machine learning,
it's constantly
optimizing so that we can focus
our time, efforts, and energy
on finding other ways
that we can continue
to connect with our members.
- This partnership
has done really
well in addressing our
business challenges.
- This is where we're looking to
continue to find the high-value
members.
We know that Google
will allow us
to continue to drive and
grow our Maven business.
[END PLAYBACK]
BELINDA LANGER: As you
can see, and as you heard,
we do our best here at
Google to make this process
effective and simple for you.
Those are some amazing metrics.
So we really want to make
sure that you can also
take advantage of
these opportunities.
Choose the action or the
actions that you want your users
to take, add your bids and
creatives, and let's get going.
But sometimes, it's
not easy to know
what bid you need to place or
start with in your TCPI or TCPA
campaigns.
It might take some experience.
So to help guide you,
we have Bid Landscapes.
And these are available
globally today,
so make sure to log into
your AdWords campaigns
and take a look.
This is a new App
Campaigns feature
that shows a bid that you should
place for your CPI or your CPA
campaigns to reach the scale
that makes sense for you,
to help you make the right
trade-offs for your business.
So you can visualize
the trade-offs
that you should consider
between both cost
and reach and compare your
performance of your app
against other, similar apps.
And as you can see in this
example, the higher the CPI,
the more installs you will get--
duh.
But Bid Landscapes help you
estimate the incremental reach
that you get for a
particular increase in bid.
It's a great tool to
guide your decision
to adjust your bid at any
stage of your campaign,
make sure that you're achieving
the returns that you need,
and that you can always
make the right trade-offs.
Sometimes, you might
actually be a little bit more
flexible, though,
with your bids.
Let's say you have
a new app launch,
or there's a new seasonal
event that you really
want to take advantage of.
Maybe you're really
focused on making sure
that people are buying those
last-minute Mother's Day
gifts-- huh?
Hint, hint.
To give you that flexibility,
we announced GDC in March
that we are also beta testing
a third bidding option--
max conversions.
With Max Conversions,
you can actually
get as many installs as
possible within your budget.
Developers, like Huuuge
Games, are already
using Max Conversions,
and it really
helped their advertising
dollars go farther, faster.
This bidding strategy
actually helped
Huuge Games drive a 300%
increase in download
volume for their Huuge Games.
And it really helped
make an impact
in the markets
and the categories
that they care about,
finding more users that were
going to engage with their app.
With Max Conversions
and Bid Landscapes,
you now have a
simple and clear way
to expand your
base of app users.
But we know that
for many of you,
installs and even conversions
don't tell that full story.
While they're a really
great starting point,
you want to grow
your app business,
so your focus should
shift towards the revenue
that each of these
users are generating.
It makes sense that
you would pay more
for someone who spends $50
than someone who spends $5.
These are basic things that
we learned in math class.
And that is why you will soon
be able to bid on the Target
Return On Ad Spend, or the
T-ROAS for each new acquired
user.
T-ROAS bidding lets you bid
dynamically and pay more
for users who are
likely to spend more,
and pay less for users
likely to spend less,
making you more effective.
And so to use
T-ROAS, you'll need
to report conversions and
conversion values to Google
Analytics for Firebase.
And for any given timeframe,
you can now specify the return
that you want to
earn from customers
relative to how much
you pay to acquire them.
In other words, when
you set your T-ROAS bid,
you're telling
Google what average
value you want to get back for
every dollar that you spent.
So let's take a
look at an example.
If you're looking for users
that will spend twice as
much as they cost
to acquire, you
can now set 200% as
your return on ad spend.
And that will be the
multiplier for your T-ROAS bid.
And it will help you
find users accordingly
who will spend twice
as much as your cost.
So if if they spend $50,
you're only paying $25.
T-ROAS bidding will be
available in the upcoming
months for App Campaigns
on both iOS and on Android.
So make sure to
be on the lookout
to take advantage of this
really great opportunity.
So I've talked about some of the
really great bidding solutions
that help you find more
of the right people
at the right price.
But today's consumers have
more choices than ever before.
Just like you guys
had many choices
of which talks to
come to, consumers
have many decisions on what
apps they want to download.
And so how do you make sure that
they're coming to your talk?
Oh, whoops-- how do
they make sure you're
downloading your app, right?
Even if you reach
the right people,
how do you win and
keep their attention?
So I'm going to take you
through some of our latest ad
creative innovations which
help you do just that.
Think back to the last
time you saw an ad
for an app you didn't know.
Giving you some time
to think about it here.
Where did you see it?
AUDIENCE: Instagram.
BELINDA LANGER:
What did you say?
AUDIENCE: Instagram?
BELINDA LANGER: Instagram?
OK, yeah.
You've seen it in the apps
that you're playing with.
Some people probably
saw it on a website.
And some of you might have
been watching a video, right?
What interested
you about that app?
What piqued your interest?
Chances are there was
something about it that
captured your attention,
making it easier
for you to take action.
And it was relevant to
what you were looking for.
But different people
have different tastes
and different goals.
We're not all the same.
So what may be
the right elements
for you may not be the right
elements for the person sitting
next to you.
It takes a lot of
time and resources
to create versions of
the apps and ads that
are relatable to
everyone, let alone
reaching them in the right
places and all the ways
that they can discover your app.
To empower Google to do a
lot of this work for you,
it's important that you
provide all the different types
of assets that we ask of you.
So it's good to make sure
that you have at least four
text ideas, videos in both
the portrait and the landscape
mode, and images in both the
portrait and landscape modes
as well.
These assets alone make
sure that you are ahead
of the pack in terms
of your creatives.
And to really
maximize your success,
we suggest you upload as
many high-quality assets
as possible in the
dimensions outlined.
And what do we do with them?
Well, machine
learning, of course.
We stitch them into
creatives, and we find out
which combinations resonate
the best with our users.
By including diverse
ad assets and formats,
Google can help you deliver
more of the relevant ads
to the right people
in more of the places
that people are looking.
And YouTube is one
of those places.
As the world's largest
video platform,
YouTube is where people go
to hang out and watch content
that they care about.
And we've opened up a
new reach opportunity
on the YouTube [INAUDIBLE] feed.
And you are able to get
more scale and more value
through your image ads.
Simply upload a landscape
image to your App Campaigns,
and you are eligible
to reach more users
on the front door of YouTube.
If you have a landscape
image, well, you
can just lean back and
enjoy all of the extra reach
that you're already
getting, because you've
got this automatically.
We even take care of
the extra formatting
to make sure that it
looks really snazzy
and catches
everyone's attention.
This means that you can
drive a lot more impact
through App Campaigns with
very little extra effort.
Another way to make sure that
you're engaging with your users
and catching their attention
is through video ads.
This is a great
way to catch people
who are in the market and
really ready to take action.
We've introduced full-canvas,
instream video ads on YouTube.
All you need to do is
upload your video assets,
and we automatically create
a panel underneath your ad
to show users more about
all the amazing work
that your team
has been building.
The panel automatically
opens once that video ad
begins to play, allowing
a user to browse through
while watching your ad.
This gives a lot more room to
communicate your call to action
and to feature all the
compelling images of all
the neat features that I
know you guys are working on
right now.
And we pull this
information directly
from the apps we're listing.
Both of these YouTube formats
are fully available today.
And we're working to bring
you even more innovations
in the future.
So once you've put your ad
in front of potential users,
the next step is to show
them why they should install
and engage with your ad.
And to do that, we've
already been talking
about how we need to
make sure your ads
are as engaging as possible.
So to help achieve this,
starting this month,
we are launching ad groups
for all App Campaigns.
Within a single
campaign now, you're
going to be able to set up
multiple ad groups to house
the creative assets and to
group distinct themes together
to tailor your marketing
message to different groups
of customers.
And this seems pretty
abstract, so let's go ahead
and walk through an example.
Let's say that you're
Headspace, a meditation app.
You can now create an ad group
for your meditation for sleep
offerings, and a
second group focused
on your stress-relieving
options.
In each ad group, you can add
images and videos specifically
catering to people who
want to unwind before bed--
something I know that I
could totally get behind.
It totally appeals to me.
Or you might want to have an ad
group focused on finding ways
that people can take
mini-meditation sessions
on the go.
You can also create another
ad group for your generic ads
with an image and a video
promoting the general benefits
of relaxing the mind.
I'm sure we could all
get behind that one.
And no matter what
your vertical,
ad groups gives you
the creative control
to pique your users'
interest with hooks
that they can relate to.
Now you may think, this is a
lot of new tools for creatives,
a lot of control.
And these all present
really great opportunities,
but they also mean that now you
have so much more information
to process.
And you have a lot
more decisions to make.
This is a lot to take in.
To help you navigate
this, we are
supporting an open ecosystem
of amazing, creative agency
partners that can work with
you to develop assets, capture
and act on all the insights that
are reporting offers to you,
and amplify your success
with all of the goodness
that we just talked about.
So today, we are so
excited to announce
a formalized partnership with
our app, Preferred Creative
Partners.
They include apptamin, Consumer
Acquisition, Kaizen, Bamboo,
Kuaizi, Creadits,
Webpals, and VidMob.
Every one of these
app-preferred creative partners
can create assets across the
entire spectrum of Google Ad
formats.
And as you can see, they have
locations all across the world.
So they have both the global
and the local insights
to help you and
guide you if you're
looking to expand your
current set of markets,
or if you're looking to expand
into new markets and regions.
You can rely on these partners
to build the best assets
to leverage the innovations
that we talked about.
Let us and let them help you
get the most out of your ads.
And you should focus on
building the best apps
that you can so
that you can come
tell me next year about
all your cool launches.
So I've shared a
few new ways for you
to grow faster with both bidding
and creative optimizations
and innovations and
the partnerships that
can take your app campaigns
to the next level.
Let's give a warm
welcome now to Duke,
who's going to talk
more about monetization.
[APPLAUSE]
DUKE DUKELLIS: Thank you.
Thank you, Belinda.
Nothing is more exciting than
growing your user acquisition,
except maybe monetizing
them to support
the livelihood of the developers
and this amazing ecosystem
that we have globally.
It's a critical component.
So I'm Duke Dukellis.
I lead product management
for apps across AdMob
and across Google Ad Manager,
our ads monetization platforms.
And I'm going to talk
to you about some things
that we're doing to really
simplify how you can make
money, make it easier overall.
OK, so we all know about IAP.
What a lot of
developers don't know,
though, is supplementing IAP--
revenue-- with ads is a great
way to grow revenue overall.
And we're even
seeing, in some cases,
this is actually
driving higher IAP.
Now, we looked at the
Google games on Play--
or games overall
on Google Play--
and we saw, last year,
a 34% growth in games
that have both IAP and ads, OK?
So something's working here.
They're finding ways
to put these together
to drive better revenue overall.
So we know this is here,
but we also it can be hard.
It can be hard to add
in ads to optimize.
And so we really think about,
how can we make this as simple
as possible for everyone,
give time back to you
to focus still on making
great games and apps?
So really, when it comes
to ads monetization,
the growth hinges on a
positive user experience, OK?
So we've got to start with
choosing the best formats.
Every app's different.
There is no one-size-fits-all.
So that's why we offer
four rich formats--
interstitial, banners,
rewarded ads, and native ads.
And let's walk through these
one by one real quickly.
And so interstitial is
these full-screen takeovers.
They have static.
They have video.
Both.
These are really popular in
apps that change screens a lot.
And it's really important you
find those natural transition
points, because you want
to minimize disruption.
And that will help you
also grow revenue overall.
Secondly, banners--
typically, we
see these as anchors
on the bottom.
And this really works well
on these single-screen apps
where you have the ads visible
the majority of the time.
And these are quite
easy to implement.
And we see them across
all different categories,
whether it's games,
or news, or utilities.
Third, rewarded ads--
now, these are opt-in.
These are most recent.
And this is about giving
the user something
in exchange for their time.
You're giving them
an in-app something.
And these are a great
option for developers
to really try to offer the
semi-premium experience.
Because a lot of
times, that user
they can't or they
won't buy right now.
So how do we give
them that flavor,
give them that semi-premium
experience, and they might
come back and convert later?
This also drives
more engagement,
because they're getting
more invested as they go.
And this is particularly
popular in games.
But what's very
exciting is we're
starting to see this crop up in
a number of other categories.
And lastly, native
ads-- and they
really let you customize
that look and that feel.
And this is great for the
developer who really wants
to go that extra mile to
make that ad blend in,
to feel like a natural
extension of the app.
And we see this great
on feeds in particular,
where it really just
feels like a natural part.
The look and the
feel are consistent.
Now, all of these formats allow
you to choose video, static,
or both.
So video is oftentimes
an overlay in this,
but that gives you
a lot of options.
And you've got a
lot of options here.
In some apps, we see
different formats--
some, all of them,
some, just one of them.
But you can really choose
what is best for your app
to get the best monetization.
So you've got the right formats.
Good.
OK, so next step is making
sure that your users
are having a safe experience.
You want tha6t
audience to feel safe.
It includes showing only
high-quality ads, and safe,
like appropriate ads for
your particular audience.
And when that unwanted
ad does appear,
you've really got to get
to it quickly, manage it
so it doesn't have an
impact on your audience.
So we've got a
unique set of tools
that we've been developing here
to make this faster and simpler
for you.
So first, I want to talk about
and introduce this new tool,
called AdMob Image Search.
So this lets you upload
a screenshot of the ad.
And we can immediately identify
the ad and all the variants
across size, and
rotation, and campaigns.
So instead of having to search
through hundreds or thousands,
and sometimes tens of thousands
of ads that are going out
to users, we make this
instant and automated for you
so we can block those ads.
Second piece is ad
content ratings--
it's something
we're very proud of.
Now, when it comes
to brand safety--
and I will say this as
a father of two girls--
nothing is more important
than making sure we're
protecting kids' experiences.
Now, with AdMob, you can
set this maximum ad content
rating to whatever you want.
So that could be G,
PG, Teen, or Mature.
And these settings can be
customized at an account level
overall.
They can be set at an app level.
And both of those can be
done with a simple checkbox
in the interface.
You don't need to
recompile and push out.
Now, if your app also happens
to serve a combination of adults
and kids, you can also,
at a per impression level,
request different ratings
based on who your audience is.
That can be done at an
impression level with our SDK.
OK, so you've got
your ad set up.
You've got your protections.
So now let's think about
running your business.
And that requires actionable
reports and analytics.
And unlike many
other platforms, we
offer insights into
both ads performance,
and also user metrics
all in one place.
And we can put the
data together and make
some really smart decisions.
And we do this without
needing to integrate an SDK--
an additional SDK.
So this can help you
optimize the lifetime
value of your customers overall
by merging these and getting
them some good insight.
So you can find out
things like, what
is my total revenue across IAP
and ads on iOS, for example?
Or how are my daily
average users looking?
What's my average session time?
What's happening there?
And now let's blend
that together.
And let me show you
an example here.
So this is our new
rewarded ads report.
So with this report, you'll
have instant access to this.
It helps you track how
changes to what you're
doing with rewarded ads are
impacting your metrics overall.
So this is really the
best way to understand,
how am I doing with my
rewarded ads implementation?
And you can answer some really
interesting questions here.
So did adding that
rewarded ad-- did
that increase my session time?
Hm.
Yeah.
Did increasing this frequency
of when I give people
a rewarded ad-- well, did
that drive my IAP up or down?
Hm.
I'd like to know.
And what percentage of
your daily active users
are actually using rewarded?
And how does it look with them?
These are all good
questions that merge
a lot of these pieces of data.
And they help you have
actionable insights.
You can immediately go
change your revenue--
immediately.
So these user reports,
the rewarded ads report--
they're all part of the
out-of-the-box solution.
You don't need to do
anything to set these up.
They just come.
You instantly get access
to that, no extra work.
All right, so the last step
I want to talk about here
is when we're really talking
about business success,
it's you want the highest
value for your ads--
every impression, highest
value-- and without spending
a lot of time optimizing.
So that's where open
bidding comes in.
Now, we announced open
bidding last year.
The idea here is quite simple.
We let all the networks
that participate bid
in to a single auction in real
time, and the winner wins.
It's that simple.
So unlike traditional
mediation, which
is how a lot of the
industry works today,
instead of having to take
average historical data
and then use that to prioritize
a bunch of different networks
and then call them in
sequence, so instead
of having to work
through all that,
we're taking all the
networks, and we're
calling them at one time.
You get the bids,
and they compete
in a single, unified auction.
So that means for
any given impression,
whoever is willing to
pay the highest wins.
That's it.
Because all these
networks are competing
at exactly the same level,
the same time, same priority,
even Google.
So not only is
open bidding going
to drive higher revenue
because everyone's
competing for each
of those users
on a real-time,
one-by-one basis,
but it's also going to decrease
a lot of the extra time
and effort that's gone
into trying to set this up
previously.
So with open bidding,
you don't have
to implement all these SDKs.
Instead, a lot of them are
sending the demand directly
through Google and
participating in that way.
Secondly, you don't need
to spend a lot of time
managing all the waterfalls.
Because if you recall,
this is one auction now.
So you don't need
waterfall after waterfall.
You're getting the
best price right away.
Now also, because we're
getting all of that
to compete in one place
and you have all the data
from the different
networks, the report
has all of the competing
networks in one spot.
So you're going to see
that in one dashboard
with completely
accurate information,
and not have to go to a
bunch of different places
to get that collective picture.
And then the last piece,
here-- so payments.
So instead of having
to go track payments
across a bunch of
different networks,
we've worked with them--
so for almost all networks,
we handle all of the
payments for you.
So you'll get a collective
check right away.
So we really simplify that
and make it easier for you.
So today, open bidding--
we've got eight partners
that are live and bidding.
So I want to call out--
we have Facebook, Audience
Network, AppLovin, and Tapjoy.
They've all recently joined,
and they're now bidding.
We're seeing great momentum
on this initiative.
And by bringing together some
of the largest, most diverse app
networks globally, it's
just driving more revenue
for our app partners.
So our partners are actually
pretty excited about this.
The industry, I
would say as a whole,
is really looking
forward to this,
because it just does everything
much, much more efficiently.
And it's good for developers.
And Vijay Balan-- so he's the
head of Publisher Solution
Partnerships at Facebook
Audience Network-- and here's
what he says.
Bidding is important in creating
a fair and open ad ecosystem.
So we're excited to work with
Google to make this happen.
This is about the real-time
bidding in one place,
in a fair auction.
With that unified auction,
developers, less time,
more money.
So our developers are
pretty excited about what
they're seeing.
So we've got dozens
of partners right now,
dozens of publishers that
are joining the beta.
They're seeing meaningful
impacts already,
including-- so let me
spotlight Sticky Hands, here.
This is a Korean app developer--
Sticky Hands.
So Minu Kim-- so
he's tried this out.
He's seen 14%
increase in revenue,
just by implementing
open bidding.
And he's seen 15%
ARPDAU increase.
And he's saying that
the revenue impact--
it's already impactful,
the revenue lift.
And we expect it to
keep getting better
as we continue to
add more partners
into that single auction.
So the momentum is continuing.
The results are already
starting to show.
All right, so as
you've seen today,
we're really invested
in helping you
do what you need to do
to build your growth
and to build your monetization.
So Belinda talked about
a few things, here--
setting the right
bid, whether that's
with T-ROAS or with
the Bid Landscapes,
and about putting your
best creative face forward
with the new opportunities on
YouTube, with the ad groups,
and with our Preferred
Creative Partner program.
And on the monetization
side, we're
really trying to help simplify
and drive higher revenue here--
simplify things like protecting
your brand with the age ratings
or with the Advanced
Creative Search,
but also to drive more
revenue through open bidding
and through better
reporting and insights
you can take action on.
Now, these smart optimizations
that we're doing here--
we're really trying to do a lot
of the heavy lifting for you,
so you can just keep
continuing making amazing apps.
So thank you, very much.
[APPLAUSE]